I was thinking I mean only if you're not
busy
anyhow next time yeah so I was looking
for cozy like oh you mean sale nah but
it ain't nice to get ya huh
hey we don't know each other yet but I'm
Felix Mills I noticed your ship in port
got to thinking you might got to hand it
to you but yes just give me a shot
that's all
sure have you changed your mom birds
from the last something in it and if
you're here for this week's I think I
got just the thing my dear she hi Greg
what's cleaning around your nails we
most folk don't got the time
oh gosh we never talked about what kind
of smells she likes I think it comes
down to what sort of intent you got if I
was looking to do a spy job Oh now if I
was a young thing trying to come on all
precious like I'd prep I guess you could
any take your time we didn't have
anything roses and I'll just wrap that
up I'll pay for that you're welcome any
time
[Music]
[Applause]
I hope this fancy soap we got Oh in her
messages June Leigh said her mama used
to make this dish from monarch dust back
casserole and then for dessert there's a
thing called there's gotta be some place
in stellar Bay that can bake a casserole
and I thanks
captain I hope you make we are now in
orbit above stellar bay captain no
blockade is a match for my piloting
skills
well most beset where she
that was a real popular meal these days
I can whip one up for you Oh what it's
all right miss I'm a cat look captain
I'm mighty glad you there we are
now if you don't mind I really need to
take a leak
my belly's gurgling just up you're a
gent oh gosh my toms rumbling just
smelling that casserole
you
the dust back cast now look how cute
these ah well I was I got this nice meal
all planned out with music in it I don't
have a head perfect there's this place I
heard of in Byzantium gellick
thanks captain
so then I told him oh we're now in open
position captain
not so fast all right you're clear
[Music]
[Music]
do we really need all the security
is it me or could each of these homes
fit all of Edgewater's cannery and all
today marks a monumental occasion in the
course of Halcyon
you with the hips
uh-uh-uh don't speak the way you rest
you aah
Celeste you I'm Celeste Charlotte
darling
I'm working on a new line of clothing
that will shock this can you don't got
to be so fordable let me get a good look
at my word I am nonsense Europe let me
do a back-of-the-envelope cap love I
don't get why that's funny oh all right
there are some now stand back and there
we are my darling what oh no ma'am I
wish you weren't so shy my vibe
can you believe this I guess that's
everything that you know there's there's
a part Jun lays been looking for to fix
up the air cyclers I know for a walk
next time we talk with ground breaker
I'm do oh this is real scary
bet for arrest space adventuring is
tiring
destination reached the groundbreaker
all right
she's on her way huh would you like a
reminder on when your next shower is
scheduled anyhow so I told him dad I'm a
big girl now
he need your help I can do it on my
lonesome What did he say to that
have at it Ben he didn't scold you for
talking back to him no he was never like
that I always thought it was funny when
I get indignant about something then
he'd watch me do whatever it was
where are we headed
welcome back do wipe the blood and space
dust from her feet okay captain she's
gone I'm near about vibrate so she got
here and well she sneeze and then she
just sort of touched my arm real
gentle-like
then I let her into the kitchen I think
she she stood Stockstill and just said I
told her how we got mr. Raymond to bake
it for us so it was double oven well we
talked a bunch over dinner about the
things we learned just when I brung out
the sweet her cakes jus but I stopped
her because I wanted to I told her about
how she made me feel and then she pulled
out a paper and read his speech she
should tell anyhow when she wrapped up
and then she sneezed again
it's all in your account you know I
don't know nothing about the law or the
cap so if you don't mind I'm just gonna
head